Oh Jack Jack I'm red daddy red daddy's
coming in right right right face but
they did it daddy washer hey guys hey
why don't you come with daddy over here
oh I saved him yeah yeah you make daddy
gay I'm a Granger face on wookies and
the winner is cinnamon toast can toast
kid no Jack don't do it over here [ __ ]
let's get him all down let's get Ken
down my marks bar guys come on guys boys
stop fighting for one second come on
boys dad Oh Jack [ __ ] oh my god ah
nope stay down here jeez yeah how do I
win I I'm so over there did I win Oh
character looks like what Ken's
character was trying to avoid become the
human centipede yeah how do I flop all
girls like me
can I be cool like you kids here dad
yeah hi guys go downstairs yeah come on
yay I like this game [ __ ] off looking
for bro
forgot forgot forgot you can't scrape
them [ __ ] yeah oh my face okay [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you hangs on a jack but nope nope
nope oh how are you alive what's that
yeah how yes baby cat oh god oh god oh
god yes ahh
grab my hand Hey please get out you what
I just want one tiny kiss before we die
please please me Oh God
is active right eyesight is as good as
it used to be seeping in there mark man
you got a few cavities in there you know
spelled oh let me help your dad now help
me [ __ ] hey table feet order up
oh yeah the ass mmm mmm how are you in
there almost got it got it
I knew you can get it free oh alright
[ __ ] you guys I'm the only one in the
track what still alive
you're dead jack you're dead jack take
my hand take my hand Josh [ __ ] Jack Jack
uh I'll just drag you off into the
off-screen here don't mind me oh there
is no more I'm dead Oh
oh well now feeling Phoenix where are
you
[ __ ] Jack oh my life with the epic
corpse take the honey oh okay
oh don't try not fight in the beginning
I'm gonna do some truck jumping okay if
you guys are parade yeah yeah yeah
absolutely
people well they're dead well you're out
of it now
alright then oh yeah alright we go for
it huh I'm gonna go for it yeah yeah
this is our superhero yeah I made it
yeah Oh looks like you buddy
you were there the whole time yeah
they're gonna fight it out whoo go gay
dudes go hey this one we have to Joe
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you that's right yeah
yeah man we got a jump how can you tell
this is stupid lag yeah yeah you know
all right hey hey hey hey hey hey hey
hey hey doing jet alright I'm gonna make
national bands jump old on kid groupers
oh yeah I'm gripping hey there are
there's no driver anyway you guys are
doing so girls good no Jack you the
superhero Oh jack hey hey hey he did ask
ya girl so I'm gonna give up you've been
holding longer than I have
I'm a diaper oh you jumped up hey I
think Felix is still inside the truck
wait what are you getting the truck
driving the truck gang oh I don't know
everybody finds so good all right geez
don't kill me a nice hug hug hug hug
hug hug hug hug oh god I miss you
without fallin oh I can't do anything i
[ __ ] god dammit like nothing hang on I
wish happening to save you again I got
it hey take my tips come on yes [ __ ]
hello the space crush that ass oh my my
oh my me I just wanted to be a part of
it
are you cool kids over here [ __ ] justing
oh wait Oh losers look at my hair flips
hair back and forth
oh gee Alex oh wow y'all right over your
feelings back pop you up man yeah oh hey
no no I want it no I want it no what the
[ __ ] happened there I saw tha have you
got worms hey Ken what you get it yes
yes yeah part a is like miley oh you
kids daddy knows how to twerk don't even
be mistaken
oh yeah like that oh yeah
hahaha beauty plier is ready
don't grab my moustache hey you toss a
yeah yeah yeah aunt Elyssa kicking it in
a sample that grunting muttering huh oh
no don't make me do it
oh boy yes your Didrik short quick
thrusts on ticks like a machine gun
I'm an English I can't live I can't live
this way like you live like a hero
thanks man